Das ist meine Sorge um meinen
Namen. Es ist vollkommen gut, zuerst seinen
Freimaurer- und Reichweiten-Ausweich- und Vinny-Trainer
als auffälligen Looper über einem Mahone's auf
Englisch zu sehen. Ok, oh ja,
ich
ärgere mich  alles
läuft gut ja ja du freust dich
auf das neue album und was für scheiß
erfolg wird es haben naja ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt
weil du weißt das
du lange an einem album arbeitest und du schreibst
neue songs die du versuchst ein besserer
songwriter zu werden a  besserer Sänger und und aber
für die Zeit, in der du an einem Album
arbeitest, ist es nur deins, du weißt, es ist, dass du
es mit niemandem teilst, es ist nur
meins, und das ist, was ich jetzt
für den Start für den Start und
dich vorbereite  wissen, April, das Album wird nicht
mehr nur mir gehören, aber ich werde es teilen
und das war das ist unumkehrbar, dann
gibt es keine Möglichkeit für dich, kein Zurück,
aber ich mag das wirklich, aber im
Moment bin ich im Übergangsmodus, aber ich bin es
bereit, es zu teilen  mit ok andere leute ist
man sich sicher über die reaktion des
publikums oder nein nein ich meine das ist die
sache natürlich kann man sich nie sicher sein
und ich finde es gut ich finde eine gesunde
dosis an unsicherheit und zweifel ich finde
es sehr gut für die kreativität weil  Es
hilft mir, mich auf die
Zehenspitzen zu stellen, um wirklich zu versuchen, nicht zu sicher zu sein,
denn wenn ich so wäre, wie sie
es lieben werden, denke ich, dass es
gefährlich wäre, weil ich mich dann vielleicht nicht
genug anstrengen würde  ok, also der zweifel ist ein
sehr wichtiger punkt angesichts der
kreation, absolut ich meine, es ist
wahrscheinlich etwas, das nie
wirklich verschwinden wird, denn als songwriter
weiß man nie, ob man vielleicht weiß,
wann immer man einen guten song schreibt, gibt es
etwas in dir, das sagt
Vielleicht war das der letzte gute Song, den du je
geschrieben hast, also weißt du es nicht genau,
aber es ist gesund, vielleicht
ist es etwas, worüber
nicht viele Musiker sprechen wollen,
weil es nicht so ist
Es ist beängstigend, weil es unbekannt ist, aber
ähm, ja, ich habe kein Problem damit, darüber zu
sprechen, weil es da ist,
und ich habe sogar versucht, es anzunehmen, und vielleicht habe
ich besonders für dieses Album wirklich versucht
, Sie wissen schon, irgendwie zurückzugehen  ein naives
Gefühl, ein Geisteszustand, in dem ich nicht zu
rational denken würde, in dem ich nicht
zu viel über das nachdenke, was ich schreibe, also
versuche einfach, meinen Kopf frei zu bekommen, meinen Kopf
von all dem Chaos der letzten Jahre
zu befreien und einfach zu versuchen, zu vertrauen  Mein Instinkt, aber ich
denke, Musik hat zwei Teile, ein Teil ist eine
Melodie und der andere Teil dreht sich
um die Instrumente. Der Sänger, okay,
es gibt mehr als zwei Teile, aber was
mehr als zwei Teile, aber ein Teil ist eine
Melodie, aber Sie können eine perfekte haben  Melodie
und es wird nicht funktionieren, wenn Sie nicht
alle anderen Teile haben, die mit
der Melodie zusammenarbeiten, also kann dieselbe Melodie
ein Hit sein oder nicht. Oh, denken Sie nicht so gut,
natürlich ist das mein Bereich, also habe ich es getan
Ich denke viel darüber nach Ich denke,
es ist zumindest für mich und ich denke a
Viele Songwriter werden dasselbe sagen oder
es genauso sehen. Für mich ist das
Schreiben von Songs eine Art
endlose Reise, die versucht, die
perfekte Balance zwischen nicht nur der Melodie,
sondern auch der Wortstruktur und dem Arrangement zu finden.
Ich denke, das ist sehr wichtig  aber das
sind vielleicht Sie kennen die Kategorien, aber
was ich nach meiner Erfahrung mit der sehr
unerwarteten Wendung von Ereignissen mit
zum Beispiel Lufttechnik oder einem Lied
wie Sie nicht weiß, dass es tatsächlich
in Belgien vor einer Technik
mit diesen Liedern veröffentlicht wurde  Ich habe gelernt, dass
es ein fünftes Element gibt, ja, das auch spielt
und nichts mit dem Song zu tun hat,
es geht nur darum, Leute zu schlagen, und ich denke,
Medien oder Radios sind empfänglich für dich
als Künstler, was nichts mit dem Song zu tun hat,
weil es so ist  wirklich, als ob
es nicht nur um Leute geht, die die
besten Songs haben oder die vielleicht potentiell
größten Hits, es hat auch damit zu tun, ob
man für oder nicht in
Mode ist, vielleicht sogar mit einigen
einige Medien oder Radio, und das liegt
wirklich daran, dass ich einen Song, den
Sie nicht kennen, sogar dreimal in
den Niederlanden veröffentlichen musste, bevor er ein großer
Crossover-Hit im Radio wurde, und es
hat mich wirklich zum Nachdenken gebracht, woher Sie die
Mechanismen kennen  weil ich
bis zu diesem Moment dachte, es ist ein Song und wenn ein
Song wirklich gut ist, wird er den Job machen,
aber in diesem Fall musste ich wohl
zwischen der ersten und der
dritten Veröffentlichung beweisen, dass ich das beweisen musste  Ich
war es wert, im Radio gespielt zu werden, okay,
was ein sehr, denke ich, ernüchternder Gedanke ist,
weil du das irgendwie nicht sehr
das ist nicht sehr nett oder nicht sehr
romantisch weißt, dass es nicht fair ist, aber ich kann
sagen, dass ich nicht pessimistisch klingen möchte
Aber Fairness ist in der Musik manchmal weit weg,
aber ich denke, Peck the Pet Shop Boys
sind alle West End Girls. Beim
zweiten Mal war es nicht so und beim
ersten Mal war es nicht dasselbe. Niemand
kennt sie und da stimmen wir zu  dass das fünfte
Element das Timing ist, wahrscheinlich huh, das Timing ist eine
Art von  Okay, danke auch, ich dachte
an die deutsche Folge eines österreichischen Künstlers
Falco und er hat seinen Weg Nummer eins. I
maddie was in human lives
den USA und er war an diesem Tag sehr
sehr traurig, weil er sagte, dass ich das nicht
wiederholen kann. Das ist das Ende meiner Karriere
Das heißt, mir sind viele Dinge
durch den Kopf gegangen, als es irgendwie
offiziell war, dass ich einen Hit hatte, und Sie wissen,
ein internationaler Hit, aber Traurigkeit war
nicht in Ordnung, um ehrlich zu sein, in meinem Fall war
ich sehr traurig, dass ich konnte.  Ich kann nicht mehr schlafen,
nein, aber es stimmt, dass ich vielleicht irgendwie
verbunden war. Ich war definitiv nicht traurig, aber ich
habe gemerkt, dass es so ist, und ich merke
auch mit diesem Album, dass es nicht
nur schwer, sondern vielleicht sogar fast
unmöglich sein wird, den Erfolg eines solchen zu wiederholen
ein erster Hit, denn das
ist sozusagen inhärent  Es ist ein Durchbruch, dass
es ein Element ist, das es erklärt,
weil es eine Überraschung ist, dass dich niemand kennt,
und plötzlich hören sie
das erste Mal, also alles, was du
weißt  Da ist
dieses erste Mal, das du beim ersten Mal kennst, und dieses erste Mal
wird nie wiederkommen, weil du
diesen ersten Eindruck nie wieder machen wirst,
und weil es irgendwie
mit dem ersten Treffer verflochten ist, bedeutet dies, dass
es wahrscheinlich schwer sein wird, dazu in der Lage zu sein
so gut machen, aber das bedeutet nicht, dass du
weißt, dass es keinen Insider gibt
, der sagt, dass du das alles kennst, du kennst
einige der größten Künstler, die sie haben,
viele große Songs und wenn
du eine lange Karriere mit vielen großen Songs haben
willst  Ich muss an einem Punkt einen ersten großen Song
haben und so, aber wir werden sehen, ich kann Sie
wissen, ich kann es total ins rechte Licht rücken,
aber wenn dieses neue Album
vielleicht kein extremes Highlight wie
ein Technologie-B haben wird  Aber auf der anderen Seite vielleicht
mehr Songs, die ein
Publikum ansprechen, und vielleicht wird es als Album
mehr Leute ansprechen, oder weißt du,
dann wäre ich wirklich sehr glücklich zu
glauben, dass es nicht mein Ziel ist, dich wissen zu lassen, dass
es so extrem war  An manchen Stellen
, an denen ich denke, das ist wahrscheinlich das,
was Männer mögen, wird es manchmal so
extrem, dass Sie denken, dass dies nicht
wirklich das ist, was ich im Sinn hatte, oder
wie es viele
andere Dinge überschattet, aber in  Mein Fall Ich muss immer noch
im Handbuch sagen, dass Sie
die ersten Durchbruchshits kennen. Ich war
wirklich froh, dass ich ihn vor zwei Jahren hatte,
als ich 27 war, denn in dem Moment, in
der ersten Minute, als der Song explodierte,
war das
so riesig  Menge anderer Songs und
Musik und Videos und diese
Hintergrundgeschichte, die online verfügbar war, war
einfach bereit für die Leute, sie zu entdecken, denn
ich hatte viele Jahre lang live gespielt, ich
hatte Musik aufgenommen, ich hatte andere
Songs, die ich geschrieben hatte, machte Videos und
Das ist etwas, das mir jetzt wirklich klar wurde
, das war definitiv mein Aussehen, das Sie
von den Männern kennen, ja, weil ich in
gewisser Weise wirklich auf alles vorbereitet war,
was passiert. Ich meine, Sie können nie
wirklich hundertprozentig bereit sein, denke ich,
weil Sie es tun  Ich weiß nicht, was passiert, aber
ich war wirklich so bereit, wie ich dachte, ich könnte es
sein, weil mir sehr wohl bewusst war, dass
ich diese letzten zwei Jahre seit der
Veröffentlichung des vorherigen Albums meine, ich hatte
nicht viele drei Tage, die ich nicht hatte
so viele tage zu hause, aber es ist wirklich ich denke jetzt
stell dir vor, wenn ich dieses album
schreiben müsste, wenn ich meine ersten songs schreiben müsste, wenn ich nach diesem
erfolg mein erstes album aufnehmen würde
, ich meine, ich weiß nicht einmal,
was ich  Das heißt, ich versuche wirklich hart zu arbeiten, aber ich
weiß nicht einmal, ob ich
es irgendwo hätte schaffen können, und das ist
leider, dass ich das als Beispiel gebe,
weil leider viele
Künstler dies tun müssen, sie haben einen
versehentlichen Treffer und  dann fangen sie an okay
okay was machen wir jetzt wir'  Ich
werde mehr Songs schreiben und es gibt so
viele Leute, die an dir ziehen, und es gibt
keine Zeit, und wir waren, du brauchst
natürlich Zeit, um erwachsen zu werden und
Fehler machen zu können, und ich kann das nicht oft genug sagen,
ich glaube wirklich fest daran, dass das so ist  Als
Musiker muss man Fehler machen können, wenn man wachsen will,
und das nicht nur hinter den Kulissen,
wenn niemand hinschaut, sondern manchmal auch
im Rampenlicht auf der Bühne oder vielleicht sogar
auf Platten auf einem Album, und das ist
etwas  Ich habe wirklich bemerkt, dass das
wirklich verschwindet, weil es so schnell gehen muss
, und sobald jemand einen
Fehler macht, bedeutet das viel Zeit, dass
es vorbei ist, ja, und das ist wirklich
anders, Sie wissen, ich habe darüber gelesen,
weil ich es war  nicht da, aber ich habe gelesen,
wie Sie wissen, auf dem Höhepunkt der
Musikindustrie, vielleicht irgendwo in den 90ern, dass
Sie wissen, wenn Sie einen Vertrag für
drei oder fünf Alben unterschreiben, und Sie würden
nach diesen Alben bewertet,
jetzt ist es nicht so  nur eine Musikindustrie  y, aber
auch das Publikum ist sehr daran interessiert, ein Konzert zu sehen
, das nicht gut ist, und es könnte sein, dass es nicht
zurückkommt. Ich glaube, ich
widerspreche dem, was ich über Sie gesagt habe, dass Sie
in der Lage sein sollten, Fehler zu machen, aber
denken Sie einfach, dass manchmal sowohl das Publikum als auch
das Publikum  Die Musikindustrie sollte
manchmal etwas nachsichtiger sein für
aufstrebende und neue Musiker, aber
die Fehler werden mehr oder weniger als jetzt
in deinem Alter und mit deiner Erfahrung in der
Musik, denkst du, oder du wirst keine
Fehler mehr machen, natürlich du  Ich weiß, um
mit dem, was ich gerade gesagt
habe, übereinzustimmen. Ich denke immer noch, dass Sie wissen, dass ich immer versuche, Sie so
gut wie möglich zu informieren
Punkt, es ist nicht
nur nicht immer genug, sein Bestes zu geben.
Manchmal gibt es einige
nette Faktoren, die Sie kontrollieren können. Sie
wissen, dass es etwas wirklich Dummes sein kann,
wie ein technisches Problem
v  oice, von dem du weißt, dass du am Ende etwas singst,
das nicht annähernd so
gut ist, wie du sein solltest, aber viele
Leute werden nur das sehen und sie könnten
denken, oh, klingt das nicht so
gut, Leben, und das sind Dinge, was  Ich
meine, du kannst leider nicht, du, ich meine,
du kannst nicht alles kontrollieren, und so
hast du versucht, das Beste daraus zu machen und
das Beste, und ich sage nur, es ist
viel einfacher, alles zu kontrollieren und
danach zu streben  Perfektion, wenn
Sie viel Zeit haben und wenn Sie
ein Konzert im Monat haben und sicherstellen können,
dass Sie es sind, Sie wissen, dass Sie
ausgeruht sind, und irgendwann versuchen Sie,
das Boot zu fahren, weil es eines der
schwierigsten Dinge ist, die ich hatte  zu lernen war,
nein sagen zu können, wenn man als Musiker anfängt,
dass man so glücklich ist, wenn
jemand einen fragt, ob man essen darf, ja ja ja
ja, weil man nie weiß, ob man nein sagt,
vielleicht fragen sie nie wieder, also
tut man ja ja, aber  das aber dann gibt es
diesen kipppunkt wo man
das in ordnung merkt  Damit Sie
klar vorausschauen und
eine langfristige Geschichte aufbauen können, in der Sie
manchmal nein sagen müssen, und es kann sein, dass
Sie eine Vielzahl von Dingen kennen, zu denen wir nein sagen können, müssen
wir uns auch selbst
schützen  nicht nur für dich, du weißt, Gesundheit
und so, sondern auch für deine Karriere.
Manchmal, wenn du dich nicht wirklich
gut fühlst, etwas zu tun, musst
du nein sagen, das ist sehr schwer, ja, aber du
musst alle öfter absagen und oft nein sagen,
weil sie es getan haben  nicht genug Zeit, denke ich
, auch noch wahr, obwohl
ich wirklich versuche, alles zum Laufen zu bringen, versuche ich, es allen recht zu machen
, das
ist ein Fehler, den viele
Sänger haben, und es ist offensichtlich,
weil wir alle dabei sein wollen  Bühne, wir
möchten, dass Sie wissen, Alben machen und
darüber reden und was wir hoffen, dass es
wirklich ein Publikum erreicht. Ich meine, wenn wir nicht würden, würden
Sie diese Art von Ich denke, diese Interaktion nicht wollen,
wenn Sie es nicht wollen, dann ich
würde nicht tun, was ich tue, okay, aber das bedeutet auch
, wenn Sie das selbstverständlich sind  e hat seine
grenzen wenn du es allen recht machen willst ist
es unmöglich du kannst es nicht
allen recht machen weil es nur sieben tage gibt an denen
er arbeitet ich arbeite an
acht tagen ich arbeite daran ich habe eine
idee die ich bekommen muss  zusätzlicher Tag in der
Woche, das würde mir manchmal wirklich helfen,
denke ich, und weißt du, dein neues Album ist,
ist es richtig zu sagen, dass es ein
Konzeptalbum oder ein Album mit einem Konzept ist,
weil Nord und Süd der Titel ein
Thema ist, das in allen Songs ist, um die es geht
Unterschiede ja, und ich denke, ich
würde es nicht als Konzeptalbum bezeichnen, aber
es ist definitiv ein Album mit dem
Konzept, okay, also für mich ist das nicht
genau dasselbe wie Konzeptalbum.
Ich denke, du weißt, dann denke ich eher an
Konzeptmusik als an dich  Ich kenne
experimentelle Musik vielleicht sogar wie
progressive Musik wie das Pink Floyd-Album
oder so. Ich meine, ich bin mir
meiner Grenzen als Songwriter und
Performer sehr wohl bewusst, also würde ich nicht so weit gehen zu sagen,
dass dies ein Konzeptalbum ist, aber  jedoch ist
es ein Album mit dem  Konzept I Ich
weigere mich, Alben als zufällige
Sammlungen von Songs zu betrachten. Wir sprechen hier nicht
von einer Wiedergabeliste. Wir sprechen nicht vom
Shuffle-Modus auf einem MP3-Player.
Album ist ein Album, bei dem Sie wissen, dass
alles stimmen muss  ein
album jedes wort wenn ich ein album mache ich
kann nur für mich selbst sprechen wenn ich ein
album mache überall das ist auf dem album
nicht da es hat einen grund es ist
nicht da es ist ein zufall
weil es das erste war
was mir eingefallen ist  Weißt du wirklich, ich verdrehe
und drehe alles aus Elfenbein Instrument
Ich spiele es auf den Kopf sogar du weißt
damit innerhalb des Artworks und im
Booklet es ist wirklich ich bin ein wirklich
unprofessioneller und ich möchte wirklich
eine Geschichte erzählen  und vielleicht macht
mich das zur alten Schule, weil du sagst, Alben,
was kümmert dich, wen interessieren
Alben? Es ist die Ära der Alben, die vorbei ist,
und nicht
nicht m  ean,
dass ich nur will, dass du weißt, gib nach und
sag, gut, ich gebe auf, nein, ich will nur noch
für die letzten Mohikaner
, die da draußen sind, die noch Alben kaufen,
ich möchte
ihnen wirklich etwas geben wollen, und das brauche ich  Ich brauche ein
zentrales Thema, ich brauche etwas,
das all diese Songs verbindet, und für
mich war das definitiv etwas, das du in den
letzten Jahren kennst, als ich so dachte,
denn das ist auch immer das, was du
tust, wenn du anfängst, neue Songs zu schreiben
, über das du nachdenkst  Ich habe geschrieben, was Sie
bisher aufgenommen haben, und offensichtlich denken Sie
über die Jahre nach,
die seit der letzten Sammlung von Songs vergangen sind,
und so war es in meinem Fall
ziemlich schnell klar, dass es
ein Album darüber werden würde  Widersprüche im
Allgemeinen und das Nord- und Südbild
und die Metapher kamen mir zum ersten Mal in den Sinn, als
ich das Lied über Belgien, das
Königreich, schrieb, und ich denke, lange
Zeit dachte ich, es würde ein
Übergangslied zwischen dem Königreich sein
Storytelling von meinem vorherigen Album
und eher von einem extrovertierten Album
wie diesem. Ich dachte, dass es
vielleicht nicht auf das Album kommen würde, weil man
diese Songs immer zwischen den
Alben schreibt und sie das neue Album beginnen, aber am
Ende nicht fertig werden  Album, das ist
eine Menge Zeit, was passiert, aber bei
diesem dachte ich nur, dass es
vielleicht nicht mehr so relevant wäre, du weißt schon, dass der I
halt, die Geschichte, die Botschaft, aber
m zu sagen, leide
war es am letzten Tag im Studi
genauso relevant wie es  war der erste Tag, an dem ich
ins Studio kam, und so, aber das wurde eingeführt,
weil ich singe, wo ich herkomme, sind sie
zwischen Nord und Süd geteilt.
Weißt du, es gibt viele
politische Spannungen zwischen dem
niederländischsprachigen Norden und dem
französischen.  Apropos Süden, ist es ein politisches
Lied, es war definitiv, es ist, es ist
, es ist das einzige Lied mit einer politischen
Dimension auf diesem Album, und sogar ich denke
an all die Songs, die ich bisher aufgenommen habe,
um es einen politischen Song zu nennen, ja, ich denke  k
, weil ich am Ende des Liedes
singe singe, wo ich herkomme, gibt es einen Mangel an
Helden sowohl in der Politik als auch in den Liedern, also denke ich,
dass es schwer zu leugnen ist, dass Sie wissen, dass
es eine politische Botschaft ist, aber ich
wollte es nicht  Ich wollte, ich wollte nicht, dass
du weißt, mache dieses Album nur
darüber, ich denke nur, dass es,
wie du weißt, nicht so interessant für mich wäre, und so
entschied ich mich, nur bei einem Song
zu bleiben, aber diese Nord-gegen-Süd-Idee zu nehmen  von
Widersprüchen und Gegensätzen habe ich beschlossen
, dies auch im Rest des
Albums zu verwenden, und jetzt liegt es nicht nur an
den Texten, sondern auch
an der Art und Weise, wie ich einige dieser Songs singe,
einige von ihnen sind sehr  weich
und einige von ihnen mit, als ich in einem
Moment hatte, als ich kaum eine Stimme hatte,
weil ich auf Tour war und ich nicht geschlafen hatte,
aber ich behielt diese anfänglichen Demoaufnahmen,
weil ich es wirklich wollte, dass es zu
perfekt ist, also weil ich es dachte
Es war schön, den Kontrast
zwischen einem menschlichen, aber unvollkommenen Vo zu haben  cal nehmen
und um es mit dir auszugleichen nicht mehr
du weißt zum Beispiel schön klingende perfektere
Arrangements und ich
experimentiere mehr mit Technologie
auf diesem Album und ich meine, du weißt mehr
mit Programm-Beats, einige der Songs
von Computern, aber besonders mit
Electronica  Ich füge Aromen
und Farben in die Songs und in die
Arrangements hinzu, was
für mich auch eine direkte Implikation des
Nordens und Südens ist, weil ich früher dachte,
du weißt, dass ich von der alten Schule bin. Ich spiele Akustikgitarre,
also meine Akustikgitarre und meine
Stimme  warm Ich meine, ich
assoziiere Wärme, aber dann gibt es die
Technologie, die Technologie genannt wird, ist
normalerweise kalt, weil sie nicht
menschlich ist, und alles, was nicht
menschlich ist, habe ich mit etwas
namens und aber ich habe versucht, Sie wissen zu lassen
, kalt und warm zusammenzubringen  manchmal in
verschiedenen Songs, aber manchmal in einem
Song, und wenn man versucht, das zu mischen,
kennt man diese diese diese elektronische
Musik mit Akustik, manchmal Vintage-Akustik  stische Instrumente, also Alben wie dieses,
wir müssen mehr darüber nachdenken. Ich denke,
vielen Dank, vielen Dank